[Musik]
wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen süßen mannschaft fällt
meine lieben freunde eventuell könnt
euch noch erinnern in der letzten
episode minecraft mit luca haben wir
diesen außenposten dahinten bestiegen
und haben uns uns deswegen so ein
bisschen mit den räubern verscherzt ich
weiß nicht ob die hier vorne noch
rumlaufen
die sind allerdings hielt glaube ich
dann hinten wieder zu dem außenposten
hingegangen die sache ist allerdings
dass die mich wirklich bisher vorne zur
wasserkante verfolgt haben und ich
seitdem oben rechts dieses symbol
eingeblendet habe was böses omen heißt
und das bedeutet dass wenn ich das
nächste mal in einem wittener dorf bin
die leute mich angreifen werden also
nicht die willicher sondern diese räuber
und ich möchte das ganze allerdings auch
heute provozieren deswegen fahren wir
jetzt an diesem eis bei kion vorbei und
verlassen unsere wüste und den
außenposten denn ich möchte wenn man
einen überfall erfolgreich meistert er
gibt der mehrere wellen die immer
stärker werden mit den monstern könnt
ihr euch ja vielleicht noch daran
erinnern als ich damals in minecraft
projekt mit luca hier auch schon den ein
oder anderen überfall miterlebt habe
wenn man diese nutzen überfall überlebt
bekommt man ein totem der und stefan
tunnel
[Musik]
china ist das denn wenn man diesen
überfall auf jeden fall meister bekommt
man ein totem der unsterblichkeit und
dieses totem der unsterblichkeit die bei
mir unten links gerade schon
eingeblendet im inventar ich habe davon
nämlich schon einige die sache ist damit
dass wenn man stirbt dass dieses tote
meer unsterblichkeit einem von dem tod
bewahrt und deswegen kann es nicht
schaden noch so ein weiteres kind zu
bekommen wenn es dann sind erwähnt
werden wenn es dann ins ende geht da
jetzt ein ganz kurzer zeit zurück zu dem
dorf fahren
[Musik]
und das sind wir auch schon wieder beim
wüsten dorf angekommen meine lieben
freunde der weg war jetzt gar nicht mal
so weit wie ich dachte also ich bin
tatsächlich jetzt gerade hier noch
anderthalb minuten gelaufen die sache
ist allerdings dass hier oben schon
eingeplant sind überfall der baut sich
gerade auf der balken dort und es ist
jetzt allerdings mit der ersten welle
wirklich noch recht easy also ich werde
jetzt mal versuchen so ein bisschen
meine hunger leiste nicht komplett zu
zerstören wird jetzt auch mal versuchen
hier vernünftig zu planen und mal ein
bisschen eine melone hier noch zu essen
so dass ich das alles hier vernünftig
auffüllt ich weiß nicht von welcher
seite die abkommen werden das ist wie
gesagt erst die erste welle das ist ganz
entspannt und da mache ich mir keine
großen gedanken die sache ist dass die
hier vorne schon wieder rum laufen von
daher jetzt nicht sprinten und die
hertha schon anhand der musik das ist
gerade noch rechtzeitig kann ja einfach
drei mal schlagen dann sterben die
schwierig wird's halt nur nachher wenn
diese komische nacht-u-bahn händlers
auch hier mit am start aber der ist ja
auch schwierig wird es wirklich nachher
nur wenn diese komischen tiere noch alle
mit ankommenden stehen hier der idiot
mit seinem komischen mannheim sei die
erste welle haben auf jeden fall
gemeistert das wird halt wie gesagt
schwierig wenn diese komischen pumper
schweine nachher kommen ein paar
sekunden später
was die amiga todes viel schaden gemacht
alter was geht jetzt aber das ist erst
die zweite welle vor gott der
pokerstars.com
das ist jetzt
nicht so ein als der hex ist sie
mittlerweile auch schon am start die
kann ich auch mal eben kurz töten und
das war jetzt auch schon die dritte
welle die wir gemeistert haben ihr seht
oben über verlegt sich wieder auf wir
müssen noch zwei weitere wellen schaffen
und das wird jetzt extrem schwierig ich
muss mir wirklich irgendwie ein spot
suchen wo ich die leute ganz gut von
abschießen kann deswegen werde ich mich
jetzt einfach mal hier hoch bauen und
gucken dass ich das von hier oben alles
so ein bisschen beobachten kann ich habe
keine ahnung von wo die kommen da hinten
schild unser händler mit seiner packers
da kommen sie an
und sie haben auch wieder eine hexe um
mit dabei
[Musik]
denn da ab
sind denn so viele hexen alter
aber der eisenkugel und verteidigt
zumindest ein bisschen mit dass ich hab
mich runter gehen sondern ein bisschen
action machen soll ich hab allerdings
ehrlich gesagt gerade noch ein bisschen
schiss vor denen ich habe leider auch
kein eisen dabei um den eisen golem hier
zu heilen deswegen ist das leider auch
ein bisschen fehlanzeige allerdings
hoffe ich dass ich es ohne den eisen
wohnung hinkriege die frage ist nur wo
jetzt der andere räuber ist da steht es
gibt einen verbleibenden räuber ich weiß
allerdings nicht wo der ist ob der sich
irgendwo versteckt ab erfolgt
steht einfach hier darum die letzte
welle meine lieben freunde der eisenbahn
wird nicht mehr lange mitmachen
allerdings habe ich zudem natürlich auch
keine persönliche bindung das hat alles
zwischen uns nie so richtig funktioniert
ich bin allerdings trotzdem froh dass er
mich jetzt zumindest ein bisschen
unterstützen konnte und jetzt schreiben
wir wirklich die letzte welle hier in
diesem komischen oper dafür mein gott
sind das wieder
oder ist das doch noch nicht die letzte
welle ich weiß es gerade gar nicht genau
[Musik]
ich habe ein halbes herz
ich schaff das nicht ich habe auch nur
noch acht brot ich krieg das auf gar
keinen fall hin ich weiß nicht ob ich
hier jetzt gerade schlafen gehen kann
perfekt perfekt wir haben zumindest den
tag so dass keiner anderen monster jetzt
irgendwie dem spawn und dann steht da
oben überfall niederlage gerade ich weiß
nicht warum das da steht da ist nicht ob
alle möglichen villiger gestorben sind
oder ob die jetzt kein gott hat
so kommen die denn jetzt alle an und
verfolgen mich was habe ich den denn
jetzt wieder getan die haben doch schon
gewonnen hätte und jetzt reitet er auch
noch von kummer es geht jetzt den hab
ich werde selbst trotzdem versuchen die
da oben mal alle zu töten und hier
zumindest im umbau und die anderen teil
der welt zu kriegen aber ich weiß nicht
wer jetzt irgendwie niederlage bei raus
kam weil ich habe doch eigentlich bin
ich doch noch am kämpfen ich habe ja
nicht ich bin ja nicht gestorben das ist
jetzt gerade das ding was ich mir
geradezu denke also warum steht da oben
hat niederlage ist das weil sie alle
villiger getötet haben weil ich die
nicht beschützen konnte oder was
passiert auch wenn ich jetzt zurück geht
zu dem ding also ich habe jetzt wieder
ein bisschen leben von daher kann ich
mich jetzt noch mal ganz kurz in den
kampf stürzen geht ihnen da vorne töten
im pumpe habe ich getötet das
schwieriger wird wirklich nur der typ
sein mit seinen komischen fliege teilen
die da immer um geflogen sind mit diesem
geist allerdings sieht es wirklich so
aus als ob der überfall vorbei wäre und
hier ist niemand mehr klar die greifen
[Musik]
ja diese dummen fliege fidschi hatten
hier die liegen alle hinter mir her
gerade was soll diese scheiße warum
kommen die immer der jedes jahr der
idiot die front hat aber den habe ich
jetzt da ist der toni umfeld und
sterblichkeit um mein gott okay wir
haben das tote meer und tätigkeit
bekommen ich habe es allerdings nicht
ein gesamt das heißt es muss gleich
nochmals zurück aber diese komischen
geistern verfolgt nicht die kriegen
jedoch die ganze zeit schaden also ich
weiß nicht ich habe keine feinde mehr
ich habe keine feinde mehr ich muss es
gehen ich muss zurück laufen das tote
meer und sterblichkeit wollen ist mir
jetzt komplett egal was ihr mit dem dorf
passiert ist ich habe auf jeden fall
fotos deren schädlichkeit ich wird
weiterhin von diesen geistern
angegriffen die leute die hier gewohnt
haben mit denen kam ich noch nicht so
richtig klar der eisenkugel am ist
glaube ich gestorben aber das mussten
jetzt einfach in kauf nehmen diese
komischen geister verfolgen mich aber
ich glaube die kriegen schaden die
werden ab und zusammen bisschen rot ich
weiß nicht was am tageslicht liegt oder
weil ihr komischer beschwörer gestorben
ist weil ich den vorhin getötet habe
allerdings verfolge nämlich wirklich die
ganze zeit die kriegen ab und zu schaden
die sind einfach böse die sind böse wenn
sie mich sehen ich dachte kriegen
schaden diesmal jetzt aber ehrlich
gesagt auch komplett
[Musik]
grossbank nicht bloß tot
wo habe ich
die ganze zeit mit gekommen zudem dinge
oder wo es bald die geister hier sind
auf jeden fall gerade gestorben als ich
ihn gelaufen bin da hinten sind noch ein
paar aber ich weiß nicht wo mein gott
auch tod
fußball
diese blöden idioten kommen doch runter
wenn du kämpfen weiter obenrum macht er
denn viele fans konnte so auch tod
fußball hier vorne legten banner ich
weiß nicht wurde er ist hier ist noch
von überfall idiot ich weiß nicht ob der
auch diese teile beschwört er hat nur
die aktien der hand um ein computer viel
schaden kate allerdings auch nochmals
markt fallen lassen nicht erst einmal
ganz kurzen brot ich weiß nicht wo balu
ist da hinten ist der händler den konten
auf jeden fall beschützen war dann noch
mal so einen geist der hier gerade rom
geflogen ist keine ahnung vielleicht was
auch ein hase allerdings bin ich ja mit
balu hier vorne um die ecke bin ich
irgendwo angekommen aber ich weiß nicht
mehr wo er ist wird doch nicht
angegriffen von denen die haben sich
doch nur auf die willicher konzentriert
dass sie sind auf jeden fall die drobs
die von dem eisen golem kamen also der
es auf jeden fall auch gestorben und
anscheinend auch die ganzen villiger die
frage ist nur ob ich mal irgendwo aus
was ihn abgesetzt habe mit einem
rechtsklick und ihn jetzt einfach nicht
wieder finde oder ob er wirklich drauf
gegangen ist aber die gehen doch
eigentlich nicht auf hunde und ich meine
ich habe ja auch nicht geschlagen die
sache ist auch wie kam ja von da vorne
vielleicht hätte ich ihn einfach sitz
machen lassen müssen ich dachte dann
kann ein bisschen frei herumlaufen aber
wo ist er denn jetzt
das ist nun scharf
da bin ich dumm schreibt mir bitte gern
mal unten in die kommentare auf ihr
irgendwas gesehen habe in dieser folge
was ich nicht so richtig mitbekommen
habe ob ich balu irgendwo doch abgesetzt
habe ob er irgendwo hängen geblieben ist
hingegen der höhle ob wir da nicht raus
kommt aber dann teleportiert er sich ja
auch eigentlich also ich weiß nicht ob
ich wirklich irgendwie aussehen irgendwo
rechts gedrückt habe oder was da los
gegangen ist kann man hier schwimmt
wieder hinten der viel mit uns rum aber
auf jeden fall eine ganz kurze time labs
wie ich zurück fahre zu meiner insel
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde da sind wir
jetzt auch schon wieder zu hause hier
auf unserer kleinen insel angekommen wie
vorhin vorderteil es bereits gesagt wenn
ihr irgendetwas gesehen haben solltet in
bezug auf blu dann schreibt sie gerne in
die kommentare
ich wurde die ganze zeit begleitet von
einigen der vielen hier auf meinem
rückblick das habt ihr vielleicht
gesehen die sonne geht auch schon wieder
unter ich werde nochmal ganz fix eben
meine wichtigsten sachen sichern so dass
da nichts mit passiert falls ich doch
noch mal irgendwie sterben sollte vom
ende wir haben wirklich eine menge
sachen bekommen hier toten der
unsterblichkeit wir haben auch ein paar
neue smaragde die brauchen wir auch noch
zum traden ich packe ich meine steine
natürlich immer rein das holz kommt hier
vorne hin und hier vorne jetzt noch so
kleinigkeiten wie den feuerstein hier
vorne habe ich noch schwarzpulver dann
hier noch redstone gold block und
goldene abführen die ganzen anderen
sachen da müssen wir uns auf jeden fall
noch mal richtig drauf vorbereiten dann
oft ende also wenn ihr weiterhin tipps
für mich habt was das ende angeht und
generell was sich eventuell in den
letzten folge jetzt noch mal machen soll
dann schreibt unten jetzt in die
kommentare und an der stelle würde ich
die heutige episode minecraft mit du
kannst auch beenden wenn es euch
gefallen hat meine lieben freunde dann
lasst sage ich ja immer die bereits
gesagt jan einen daumen hoch unter dem
video abonniert main kanal und klickt
auf die glocke in die nächste episode
minecraft mit luca nicht verpassen wollt
wir werde der nächsten episode das
machen was ich mir jetzt in die
kommentare schreiben könnt also tippt
irgendwas unten rein was ich machen kann
in der nächsten folge und schreibt mir
auch bezirk jahren was ich mit balu
gemacht habe ob er dann noch irgendwo
schild oder was man ihm vielleicht hätte
passiert sein können wir sehen uns dann
in der nächsten folge wieder und
ja ich bin einfach gerade froh dass wir
ein anderes tote meer und sterblichkeit
noch bekommen haben
[Musik]